goosebumps - haunted Halloween is the
sequel to the surprisingly not terrible
first film that I was terrified to see I
was so afraid to see that movie because
the Goosebumps books as I said in that
review were the books that got me
interested in writing when I was a
little kid and reading them really got
me interested in telling stories and
I've always felt indebted to RL Stine
for inspiring me to use my imagination
when I was in elementary school and that
first film was actually kind of okay and
I really kind of enjoyed it and I've
watched it since then and still enjoy it
I think it's a really good family
Halloween film so the sequel stars two
young kids who weren't in the first who
are trying to start a junk business and
they get an anonymous call to go to this
old house and clean up all the junk out
of it this ends up being the old house
of RL Stein and they find in it slappy
the dummy who starts to wreak havoc on
their little town this film is not as
good as the first one unfortunately it
has a smaller budget according to Box
Office Mojo the budget for this film is
about thirty-five million dollars
whereas the budget for the original was
over fifty million dollars a lot of the
original cast could not return due to
other projects that were already in
development that would conflict with
this and it seems like Sony Animation
Studios decided to just make a
completely different movie and rush it
and get it out in theatres and have a
smaller budget because having a return
on their investment would be nice and
goosebumps is a big property and so I'm
not against a whole new cast I mean look
at the Goosebumps books themselves
they're filled with different characters
it just feels like Sony really wanted to
get a sequel out so they rushed a lot of
elements making the end product feel
very disposable it's not terrible by any
means I mean there's there's no part of
the film where I was offended watching
it or hurt I didn't feel like my
childhood was being trampled on or
anything it's just an okay movie the
young actors in the film do mostly find
their neighbor ken Jeong he's just there
to tell jokes every once in a while and
he sort of plays a version of himself
that we've seen in mini films where he's
like always popping up in a movie as
like this comedic side character it's
like his thing he's always a supporting
character in a movie who tells jokes
really quick and then he never
again and he's doing that again yeah
that's like all I ever see him do in
movies and it didn't really feel like it
had a place in the movie unfortunately
the plot of the first film the idea of
RL Stein's book's opening and all of
these creatures and monsters and
terrible things come out and wreak havoc
on this town that's such a great idea
the plot this time around once you
uncover what's actually happening with
slappy and what he wants to do it's kind
of laughably stupid and it's certainly
not very scary which is unfortunate
it's just kind of weird and a little
awkward and it's just more embarrassing
than scary but there is a nice excuse to
have a bunch of creatures roaming around
again doing things again but the CGI is
unfortunately kind of subpar more subpar
than you would expect for a movie that
costs over thirty million dollars it's
nowhere near as good as a CGI in the
first film and even that film's CG it
wasn't like mind-blowing or anything it
was just competent this time around it's
really not that good and some of it
looks almost TV production quality which
I find very strange because Sony
Animation Studios is these this isn't
like you know some nobodies these guys
have some serious money their disposal
and again it just feels very rushed but
what was most disheartening to me while
watching the film and again III must
reiterate this is not a terrible film
it's just fine it's okay but I think I
went in with higher expectations and
most people the direction in the film is
so listless it's not bad it's not good
it's just there there's very little
energy it just feels like there wasn't a
lot of passion for this material which
again the material is not that great but
you can take subpar material and enhance
it with some really energetic direction
and some fun pacing and movement with
the camera and it's just not there and I
feel like a mistake that some studios
and writers and filmmakers make is
assuming that because they're making a
film aimed at children that children
aren't going to care that much and that
might unfortunately be true but I do
remember being a kid being blown away by
being something magical I mean I went to
the theater and I saw movies like jingle
all the way I remember seeing that film
and but I don't remember really anything
about it but I remember sitting in the
theater watching Lion King I remember
films like Toy Story and how much they
blew me away and it just bugs me when I
see a children's film that just feels
like it's just released like here you go
we did it we finished it on time and we
made it for you but most families are
going to walk out of this theater having
a good time this isn't the type of film
where you leave thinking why did I waste
my money watching that there's one last
choice in the film I want to talk about
that bugged me and it's this early
subplot involving the older teenage
daughter and a boy she likes at school
she goes to a club and she sees
something that makes her sad she runs
away and she's crying and I'm like when
I think of goosebumps I definitely don't
think of teenagers at clubs and I don't
think of romance drama but it's in the
film for some reason and it's kind of
pointless
I mean RL Stein had goosebumps and that
was for kids but he also wrote Fear
Street that was for teenagers there are
scenes in this film that feel like the
worst fear Street books where it's just
like teen romance stuff and that was
surprising and kind of out of place for
me towards the third act it gets a bit
better because some stuff happens that I
didn't know was going to happen that
helps the proceedings quite a bit and I
don't want to get into spoilers but you
know some stuff occurs and you're like
okay all right this is more like what I
wanted um I just wish that there was
more of that throughout the whole film
and I wish the director gave more care
to this material and tried to make a
film that was more than just a studio
product I'll give goosebumps to C+ you
may have been expecting a lower grade
but like I said it is watchable it's
fine
like it's totally fine it's just there's
certain negatives about the film that I
really wanted to talk about and I just
kept seeing all these ways the film
could have been better but most families
are gonna have a totally okay time with
the movie guys look forward to my review
of bad times at El Royale coming to you
very soon as well as the start of our
sixth annual Halloween special my wife
and I are going to have a lot of videos
coming to you very soon some reviews
doing I love doing that every year thank
you so much guys if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]